hallo meine Lieben wir machen heute
Apple crumble Muffins ein ganz ganz
einfaches leckeres und super saftiges
Rezept ihr braucht doch gar nicht so
viele Zutaten ich liste sie euch wie
immer hier unten in der Infobox auf
einfachen Screenshot machen einkaufen
gehen im besten Fall dabei Kaufland und
das ganze nachmachen bei mir ist so der
basic-einkauf zum Backen und
grundsätzlich soll man Einkauf äh der
findet immer bei Kaufland statt weil ihr
dort eben alles bekommt und ich gebe
jetzt erstmal die Butter in eine
Schüssel weil ich jetzt erstmal die
Streusel machen werde und dafür müsst
ihr die Butter einfach nur in der
Mikrowelle zerlassen ganz ganz wichtig
geringe Wattzahl also nicht dass euch
die Butter Platz sondern habt ihr eine
riesen Sauerei so und da kommt jetzt
eben auch noch Rohrzucker mit dazu der
braune Rohrzucker das ist diese Packung
hier das schmeckt einfach noch mal so
ein bisschen karamelliger also wenn ihr
den ähm mitnehmt wäre das super auch
grundsätzlich für Backrezepte wenn ihr
einfach so ein karamelligen Geschmack
noch mal möchtet da kommt jetzt auch
noch ein bisschen Zimt mit rein könnte
die Option noch weglassen passt aber
super zu den Äpfeln und ganz normales
Mehl das ist hier Weizenmehl Typ 5 das
nehme ich immer zum Backen da könntet
ihr jetzt auch Dinkelmehl Typ 630 nehmen
wenn ihr möchtet funktioniert beides
sehr gut jetzt einfach mit den sauberen
hinten da reingehen und zu Streuseln
verarbeiten
[Musik]
zu den Streuseln habe ich jetzt noch so
ein paar gehackte Walnusskerne mit dazu
gegeben weil ich finde das passt einfach
perfekt geschmacklich ihr könntet auch
Mandeln oder Haselnusskerne dazugeben
oder das ganze einfach weglassen wenn
ihr keine Nüsse da drin haben möchtet so
ganz kurz zur Seite geben weiter geht's
jetzt mit unserem Muffinteig dafür
benutze ich heute die Küchenmaschine ihr
könnt natürlich auch euer Handrührgerät
verwenden und ganz ganz wichtig ist dass
die Butter Zimmer warm ist also
rechtzeitig aus dem Kühlschrank nehmen
am besten so anderthalb bis zwei Stunden
vorher das gebe ich jetzt hier einmal
rein und da geben wir dann auch schon
Zucker mit dazu hier habe ich mich dazu
entschieden weißen Zucker und auch
wieder braunen Rohrzucker zu verwenden
einfach im Verhältnis halb und halb weil
ich möchte das auch hier wieder so ein
karamelliger Geschmack zum Vorschein
kommt so und da könnt ihr dann auch
schon Zimt und diesmal auch noch ein
bisschen Vanilleextrakt mit reingeben
das ganze dann 3 Minuten lang schön hell
cremig mixen und anschließend
nacheinander die Eier dazugeben
[Musik]
so die zwei Eier haben sich jetzt gut
mit dem restlichen Teig verbunden jetzt
fehlen eigentlich nur noch die trockenen
Zutaten und zwar mehl und Backpulver und
auch noch mal eine flüssige Zutaten
Milch und damit wir den Teig jetzt so
geschmeidig wie möglich hinbekommen das
ganze am besten abwechselnd machen ich
nehme jetzt hier auch mein Sieb da gebe
ich jetzt schon mal mehl und Backpulver
mit rein aber ich sieht noch nicht alles
durch ah ich sehe schon ich sehe schon
kommen es wird mir auf jeden Fall
daneben um die Ohren fliegen aber ich
mache das jetzt so
hier ist das erste deutsche Fernsehen
mit der Tagesschau
[Musik]
rein schon mal ein bisschen reinziehen
Backpulver gebe ich auch schon mal mit
dazu so und ich mache das so dass ich
einmal halbiere also die Hälfte kommt
jetzt mit rein wird schön gemixt und
dann gebe ich währenddessen die Hälfte
der Milch mit dazu und dann kommt eben
wieder Hefte von der Backpulver
Mehlmischung und ganz zum Schluss die
restliche Milch und dann ist der Teig
auch schon fertig
[Musik]
so ganz so fertig ist der Tag noch nicht
da können wir noch Äpfel rein die habe
ich einfach geschält und in kleine
Würfel geschnitten die Schale mag ich da
jetzt nicht ganz so gern könntet ihr
auch machen aber ich finde dass die
weiche Schale dann so ein unangenehmes
Mundgefühl macht ist einfach hier mit in
den Teig reingeben am besten eignen sich
übrigens säuerliche Äpfel so Elster
Granny Smith also ihr seht auch bei der
Beschreibung auf der steht säuerlich
oder süß und säuerliche Äpfel passen
einfach geschmacklich am besten zu süßen
Rezepten so jetzt einmal schön
unterheben ist doch gar nicht schlimm
dass die jetzt weil ich ein bisschen
nicht verquatscht habe und wir müssen
geredet haben dass sie da so ein
bisschen braun geworden sind das ist gar
nicht schlimm weil die werden ja sowieso
gebacken ich sehe auch oft dass da noch
Zitrone drübergegeben wird damit sie
nicht braun werden aber sie werden ja eh
gebacken und den säuerlichen
Zitronengeschmack brauche ich darin
jetzt nicht dafür habe ich ja die
säuerlichen Äpfel hierzu ein kleiner
Tipp das ist für mich ein absoluter Game
changer ich habe nämlich eine Muffinform
mit relativ großen Muffins also das ist
jetzt keine normale zwölferform könnt
ihr auch machen verrate ich euch auch
gleich die Backzeit wenn ihr normale
12er Muffin in Trey habt ist gar kein
Problem aber bei den großen könnt euch
einfach ein Backpapier nehmen ein großes
Quadrat ausschneiden dann alle vier
Seiten einmal einschneiden die Mitte auf
jeden Fall freilassen nicht
durchschneiden und dann habt ihr die
perfekte Muffinform die nebenbei bemerkt
auch richtig schön herbstlich aussieht
so kleine Förmchen weil man hat ja auch
wirklich nicht viele Grüße die perfekte
Form so jetzt nehme ich mir meine
ICE Portionierer weil ich finde dass man
damit immer am besten überall ankommt
und portionier den Teig gleichmäßig in
jedes Förmchen und wie gesagt die
Backzeit variiert weil das jetzt sechs
große Muffins sind und bei einem 12er
Tray braucht das ganze 22 Minuten ich
denke hier werden es ja bestimmt so 30
mindestens
[Musik]
bloß nicht den besten Part vergessen und
zwar die Streusel oben drauf verteilen
und dann kann aber gebacken werden ich
finde so mit Streuseln und Teig und
diese saftigen diese saftige Apfel Note
sind das für mich die perfekten Herz
[Musik]
das sind mal dicke Muffins also mir
gefällt es schon fast besser dass sie so
groß sind und dass man wirklich viel
davon hat ich meine gut ihr könntet auch
zwölf kleine machen aber mir gefällt das
richtig gut und oh Jasmin da musst du
noch mal ran bei beiden die sind so
saftig aus also ich finde so Apfel mit
Streuseln das ist einfach so die beste
Kombination die man haben kann ich rufe
einfach und gönn mir jetzt für euch
also
zehn von zehn Punkte die Streusel sind
super knusprig dann weißt ja aber auf
diesen unfassbar saftigen Teig der
wirklich wie so ein Flummi also so
richtig saftig einfach hammer
Kombination zimt ist perfekt also ich
Zimtnote die Vanille-Note ist perfekt
Leute macht unbedingt nach also wenn ihr
nach diesem Rezept nicht voll im Herbst
weit seid dann weiß ich auch nicht
weiter und ja wie gesagt das ist euch
dann schmecken schreibt mal Feedback auf
jeden Fall unten in die Kommentare wenn
es nachgemacht habt und schreibt mir
gerne weitere apfelwünsche in die
Kommentare aber ich bin mir sicher ich
habe schon so eine riesen Bandbreite das
meiste habe ich echt schon lassen aber
gerne immer wieder was Neues einfallen
und ja dann würde ich sagen können wir
das jetzt hier noch mit meinem
Cappuccino und sage bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
[Musik]